talk about the off season talk about the
things that were uppermost in your mind
and one of those was getting the players
to play to put it bluntly um and so how
do you feel like you have addressed that
and and gotten to a point where fans can
say you know what when I go to the arena
when I pay my money I'm going to see the
guys I want to see yeah most importantly
we addressed it by working directly with
the players and the Players Association
I think everybody understands that the
fans this is about the fans we're an 82
Game season
that ultimately that if a player is
healthy the expectation is he's going to
be on the floor playing by the way I I
you know it's also important to make
clear this isn't about turning the clock
back I mean guys who played this game
before played often at times when they
probably shouldn't have been out there
and so it's not about making guys go out
there when they're injured they
shouldn't be playing it's about healthy
guys playing it's an it's an
understanding that ultimately that this
is about the fans there's an
expectations whether the that family in
the arena or family watching on TNT that
they want to see the best players on the
floor I understand the rules but how can
you enforce it because you know a lot of
times if I say I'm I'm hurting I can't
play but like you can't really judge
pain all the time so how are you going
to enforce this law well that that's a
great point and as a last resort we'll
bring an independent doctors to look at
Players but that's where I started by
saying this is about the relationship we
have with the players and the player
association this is about a partnership
it's about understanding what drives
this sport what drives the business of
this Sport and that's seeing the best
players on the floor there are a few
things though for example the 65 game
minimum we put in the collective bargain
agreement again the expectation isn't
that guys will play only 65 games that
that's a minimum based including
injuries but also notion that the league
has set a policy we're getting directly
involved we're creating incentives for
them to be on the floor to be eligible
for certain Awards and again I don't I
don't think this needs to be adversarial
it's not the league against the players
I think when we sat across from the
players in collective bargaining and
discussed this there wasn't any
disagreement in the room about what we
needed to do yeah I I agree you know and
and just last point on that a lot of
that also is management you know load
management comes from the management of
the you know Executives all of those
devices that the players are wearing
aren't Player devices those are devices
that are given by the teams so the teams
come out and say hey
this is an opportunity for you to sit
down you've hit a threshold so it's
collectively working with not only the
players but also the team owners and
Team Management letting them know like
we need to we need to have the Kenny
that's a great point and and I want to
make clear this isn't about the players
not wanting to play to your point load
management was a concept that came from
our teams a belief that by strategically
resting players they were going to
perform better later in the season and
the fact is having had a bunch of
seasons of data now frankly to look at
it it's not proven in any way that it's
effective in terms of keeping in fact
injury rates haven't declined at all
despite the load management so part of
it is also just looking at the
experience now we've had around that
concept and recognizing that it's it's
not advantaging
anyone well let me say
this I'm talking to the players man
forget the ownership forget the fans as
a
player if you're going to make 5060
million a year to play ball basetball
three or 4 days a week play basketball
man now if you're injured if you're
injured don't play but everybody Hurts
after the first two weeks of the season
your your legs sore your knee sore if
you're injured I don't want you to play
but the notion that number one bless
these guys you're making 3040 $50
million to play basketball four days a
week y'all got the best shoes you got
the best medical staff you got these
guys sleeping in Chambers you got I
baths man if you can play shut the hell
up and
play I don't know that there was a
question in there to you it wasn't a
question